this next story is absolutely insane
it's dystopian it's it's really straight
out of a handmaid's tale much like some
of the people donald trump is
considering
for the supreme court to replace ruth
bader ginsburg although we'll get to
them
on tomorrow's show but it is now alleged
that the united states in 2020 under
donald trump
is performing forced sterilization
unwanted hysterectomies on women
detained by donald trump's ice
immigrations and customs enforcement
forced
sterilization is what we are talking
about here
prism has learned according to a source
familiar with the situation
that gynecologist mahendra amin
based in georgia has been performing
forced
sterilizations as per prism the
organization's project
south the georgia detention watch
georgia latino alliance for human rights
and georgia
a south georgia immigrant support
network have filed a complaint on behalf
of immigrants
detained by the united states
detained inside of icdc which is
operated by private prison company
lasalle corrections
and the organization alleges that five
women
could be more but this specific
complaint refers to five women
sterilized at the facility between
october
and december of last year don wooten
a licensed practical nurse employed by
icdc is the whistleblower and she says
i've had several inmates tell me that
they've been to see the doctor
and they've had hysterectomies and they
don't know
why they went or why they're going a
spokesperson for the southern poverty
law center
which has represented people detained
there confirmed to prison
that dr amin saw multiple women
represented by the organization the
spokesperson couldn't currently
uh confirm the extent of the
appointments and according to the
whistleblower in the project south
complaint
amine recently took out the wrong ovary
on a detained woman the women do not
appear to be consenting to getting
hysterectomies they are not receiving
translation services
many times there are language barriers
when they are
getting complicated medical information
conveyed to them they have no translator
sometimes nurses are reportedly
communicating using google voice on
their phones to translate
google translate on their phones rather
or by asking
other detainees to translate that's not
how we do things
or i thought we weren't doing things
that way in the united states
and one woman was given three different
explanations
about what is being done to her
medically this
is some of the ugliest stuff that we've
heard of there if you go back and look
at us history
there is an ugly history of reproductive
injustice in the united states
the tuskegee experiment used
african-american
sharecroppers to test and understand
syphilis with researchers refusing to
tell patients
that they have syphilis or to treat them
in order to see what happens
with untreated syphilis men were denied
treatment and many died or went blind or
insane
the american doctors behind the birth
control pill
first tested the birth control pill on
low-income
puerto rican women there have been
nationwide eugenics campaigns targeting
wide swaths of people for sterilization
because they were
considered undesirable so there's a
history of this and it's happening now
and it gets even worse the doctor
dr mahendra amin appears not to even be
a board-certified ob gyn they are a
gynecologist
but a spokesperson for the american
board of obstetrics and gynecology
said to the daily beast that according
to their records dr
mahendra amin is not even certified now
it's sort of like the icing on the cake
right
shocker that the trump administration's
choice of doctor for forced
sterilizations is not board certified
but it's just another detail in the
insanity
um ice is not commenting about the
certification
of dr amin and we have we are in the
process of trying to figure out
what the hell is going on here the
obvious question is is doctor
amin going to be prosecuted probably not
is he going to be made surgeon general
seems like as reasonable of a question
uh given the insanity of this
administration
this really is uh uh th
this is concentration camp stuff um if
it's even a fraction of what's being
alleged it is the worst of the worst
and we really need to remind ourselves
as a country
that we have committed atrocities in the
past
and we've made improvements but things
are still going on
we can't put our guard down for a moment
the vigilance must stay and when you let
lunatics in power bad things
happen it's not just elections have
consequences
it's also not paying attention
even for a moment has major consequences
human rights abuses
it it's it's dystopian i'm almost at a
loss for words and unfortunately we are
repeating some of the worst things from
american history
right now it's having an effect on our
reputation and that's what i want to
talk about next
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches
and they're giving you up to 30 off
everything in their store
when you go to davidpakman.com watch
if you're looking for an awesome way to
update your look
the perfect way to do it is with an
elegant high quality
wrist watch when there's a company like
vincero
there is no reason to go spending
thousands of dollars on a watch vincero
is an american company that's made it
possible to own
an excellent watch without breaking the
bank all of their watches are
masterfully built with high-end
materials
but they're all in the range of about
150 to 250 bucks
i just got a watch from their icon
automatic collection
the one i got is in gunmetal and slate
blue
i love the look it's sleek classy it's
clear that a lot of careful
craftsmanship went into the design
it is definitely my new favorite watch
you'll get up to 30 percent off
everything in their store
when you go to davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video